Thank you to audible for sponsoring this
video.
Guys,
early in May,
the German offensive began along the
front extending from course the prime
area.
More of the world was afraid.
Russian campaigns have been smaller,
but Germans were the span threshold
would
still fail to simultaneous attacks from
the north,
from the south
was tussled with the banks.
We're getting castle instead of the
Russians
are not only a field barney,
he lost his firearm.
One million,
one hundred ninety three thousand five
hundred twenty five million,
800,000.
I just
wanted him because he looked get it,
but she wouldn't be tufted veal.
This is the story of Stalingrad.
This is a story of Stalingrad.
This is the story of Stalingrad,
the story of honorable but naive German
men.
The story of the Soviet fighting spirit
against a brutal enemy,
the story of the victims of a regime
during the heroes of their country.
The sort of conflicting stories of
Stalingrad
eat mgm and what is that you've asked
them in Manhattan,
is a charging through the heart of the
Soviet Union towards the oil fields of
Asia.
One last obstacle remains.
Yeah.
My
vehicle,
which
may
decide
to
get
it,
hopefully
I'm annoyed with Sasha for not staying
at home,
has it made you swear to do it?
I'm going to have to do,
which
is kind of minded.
She's making these cleansing plans
to have him come on and
try
when you show them
intake
to called Leonardo,
we should trust the instate
managed to lead us to victory.
Now,
whatever
the
city
styling,
styling Grad,
no,
just always happening.
Deport the families of the.
I
have no illusions.
That's the learning to socialism in
universal bliss.
Wow.
There's always something to
give it up.
He was under the foot soldier,
wasn't worth giving away my position.
Did we just see the dealership
to
the battle of Stalingrad remains such an
ideologically charged and symbolically
important subject that the last word
will not be heard for many years,
and therefore the story of Stalingrad is
to German story of coping with the
darkest chapter in its history.
Attempting to redeem a disgrace
generation by putting the burden of
guilt on those in a position of power.
It's the Russian memory of the patriotic
war against a brutal enemy.
His statement for to resolve with the
Red Army,
but it's also the western Narrative
Stalin Grad as a struggle for markable
victims,
caught in between two murderous regimes,
more so than actually capturing the
history of or attempting to portray
these narratives.
Leave us with a broad variety of
symbolic perspectives on the battle
perspectives that reveal how to involve
countries,
choose to understand their past,
showcasing the subjectivity inherent in
our perception of history and now did
our post memory of the war is becoming
increasingly reliant,
unmediated images of the past.
The question that arises then is to what
degree evil or cinema and our media both
consciously and unconsciously influence
and perhaps reshape how we come to view
to war in the best in general through
day,
broaden our perspective and help keep
the history alive or are they bound to
distort and revise the actual history in
the minds of the viewer.
Whatever your opinion on the matter may
be.
The film's about styling garage.
Showcase how both filmmakers,
storytellers,
and audiences alike.
Shoot at the very least,
be aware of the implications of boasts
memory.
Constructed through two perspectives of
works of fiction and to be mindful of
what we're trying to say and what we're
being shown about our history.
Thank you all for watching and thank you
to audible for sponsoring this video.
Audible is a service providing an
unmatched selection of audio books,
spending every genre you can imagine by
signing up through our special link at
audible.com/storytellers or by texting
storytellers to 500,
500,
you'll get a free 30 day trial as well
as any free audio book of your choosing.
Personally,
I would highly recommend you check out
anthony beaver Stalin Grad,
narrated by Peter Noble.
It's one of the most detailed,
compelling and intensive counts with the
board and I've ever read a transporting
you back in time.
Looking at the struggle from the
soldier's perspective all the way up to
Hitler and Stalin themselves.
I love Anthony [inaudible] work and
Peter Noble does a great job and
bringing his writing to life as a
narrator.
If you're even remotely interested in
learning about the bloodiest battle in
human history,
this is the audio book for you.
To me,
the best thing about audible is that you
can spend your time more productively
and efficiently by listening to your
audio books on your daily commute when
you're working out or when you're doing
the dishes.
For instance,
you can even increased innovation speed
if you have multiple books to get you up
on every month.
Members get a free audio book,
special discounts,
and even 30 percent off,
all regularly priced audio books,
so again,
you can sign up through
audible.com/storytellers or by texting
storytellers to 500,
$500 by signing up today.
You not only help yourself to a great
deal,
but you also help support us in our
efforts to make more videos.
Also,
if you like what we do,
please consider leaving us a dollar on
Patrion or paypal.
Thank you.